The solution to this question
is ListPreference.
When the setting is tapped, it presents
a list of choices as a dialogue.
When the user selects an option,
it's saved into Shared Preferences.
Here are the steps to do this.
Within the pref_general.xml file,
we add a list preference.
We give it a title, and this maps
to the string temperature units.
We also need to give it a key
for the shared preferences,
and so we specify that to be units.
If there is no value
in shared preferences,
then it falls back
to a default value of metric.
The preference also wants to know
the list of all possible values here.
The two possible values
are metric or imperial,
so we pass those in as an array,
into entry values.
Now, these are just constants
for use within the logic of our app.
These are not the user visible strings.
So we need to create entries
which is an array of user visible strings
that maps to each one
of these possible values.
To have the temperature unit preference
show up in the settings activity,
we modify the on create method.
We add this line of code
for the temperature units setting.
When the user makes
a selection in the dialog,
we set the preference summary
to be the new value
of either metric or imperial.
Here, when we receive
a high and low temperature,
we read from shared preferences
to know whether the temperature
should be converted
to imperial units or left as metric.
Then we return the formatted string
for display in the UI.
That completes the code
for saving the temperature unit setting.